2004's "Saw" was a career-making movie for
many people.
Whether their roles were large or small, many
of the actors in this little-horror-movie-that-could
either had, or went on to have, surprising
careers.
We want to play a game called "What happened
to the cast of Saw?"
Cary Elwes is probably best remembered for
his dashing and deadpan performance in The
Princess Bride, but he's also played a lot
of jerkish, self-centered foils, as in "Twister,"
and creepy antagonists, as in "Kiss the Girls."
"Saw" split the difference, casting him as
the selfish, jaded Dr. Gordon, who has to
spend the film growing into someone viewers
will root for.
Lawrence gets put through the wringer, and
his suffering and character growth gives Elwes
the chance to deliver a juicy and intense
performance.
You can call it over the top — and plenty
of critics did — but Elwes sells it.
"I've done it!
Now show them to me!"
So what's he been doing since then?
For starters, he returned to the franchise
in Saw 3D, another Jigsaw victim who converted
to the killer's philosophy.
Outside of that, he's worked steadily, usually
releasing a handful of films each year.
With appearances in 2019's "Black Christmas''
remake, "Stranger Things" season 3, and the
acclaimed "Ghost Light," he seems to have
found a new home in horror, which tends to
be loyal to its favorite stars.
Best of all, he also landed a role in "Mission:
Impossible 7," bringing him into one of the
most solidly entertaining franchises around.
"Saw" co-creator Leigh Whannell's acerbic,
vulnerable Adam is a key part of what makes
the first "Saw" movie work, but he's arguably
even more important as the screenwriter.
While Whannell's acting career has stayed
small, mostly limited to fun supporting roles
in the "Insidious" franchise and horror films
like "The Bye-Bye Man," he's become a horror
staple as a writer and director.
He stayed on with "Saw" for a while, writing/co-writing
the scripts for the second and third movies,
and then moved on to the clever supernatural
thrills of the "Insidious" movies.
His directorial debut on "Insidious: Chapter
3" got an uneven reception, but with 2018's
sci-fi/action film "Upgrade," he started knocking
it out of the park.
With the release of 2020's widely acclaimed
"The Invisible Man," the sophisticated and
pulse-pounding film starring Elisabeth Moss,
Whannell officially became one of the most
exciting horror directors to watch.
Danny Glover needs no introduction.
With the "Lethal Weapon" series and "Predator
2" under his belt — plus roles in prestigious
films like "The Color Purple," "Silverado,"
and "The Royal Tenenbaums" — he's a household
name.
With Saw's low budget, it's impressive the
film snagged him at all.
He plays Tapp, a former detective who becomes
obsessed with proving that Dr. Lawrence Gordon
is the Jigsaw Killer.
His involvement in the case gives viewers
context for Jigsaw's terrifying string of
murders, and his investigation further amps
up the tension.
Glover's life and career have been as busy
as ever.
He's stayed deeply involved in activism, passionately
advocating on issues ranging from labor unions
to international affairs and civil rights.
His filmography since Saw's release has continued
to be an impressive blend of critical and
commercial successes, artistic risks, and
guaranteed crowd-pleasers.
Basically, Danny Glover can do anything, and
he's proved it by doing everything, in some
jam-packed and incredibly successful years.
Ken Leung's doomed Detective Steven Sing might
meet a bad — but undeniably memorable — fate
in Saw, but Ken Leung has luckily done much,
much better in life.
He was a little bit of a name before Saw,
especially given his villainous turn in "Rush
Hour," but he found some of his most notable
career successes after Detective Sing died
in a shotgun trap.
In particular, he attracted a lot of attention
for a memorable guest-starring spot on "The
Sopranos" that the Washington Post pegs as
being one of the turning points in his career.
He went on to play series regular Miles on
"Lost," a fan-favorite character from the
back half of the show's run that many viewers
wish they'd gotten to see more of.
Leung also had recurring roles on “The Blacklist"
and "Zero Hour" and was a series lead on medical
drama "The Night Shift."
His film work hasn't been quite as high-profile,
but it's still been impressive, with roles
in "Star Wars: The Force Awakens," Spike Lee's
heist thriller "Inside Man," and Noah Baumbach's
"The Squid and the Whale."
Dina Meyer has been a familiar face to genre
fans for years, appearing in everything from
the satiric Starship Troopers to Star Trek:
Nemesis; she was even a series lead in 2002's
Birds of Prey.
Playing a hard-boiled detective in Saw probably
seemed like a natural move for her career.
The film wound up doing a lot for her.
For one thing, she would go on to become a
major part of the franchise, appearing in
Saw II and III and staying a continuing part
of the series' lore in IV, V, and Jigsaw.
Aside from the Saw series, most of Meyer's
major work has been on TV, with guest spots
on almost every show you could think of: NCIS:
Los Angeles, The Magicians, Criminal Minds,
CSI, and more.
In the first Saw film, Mike Butters plays
Paul, the man who died in Jigsaw's razor wire
trap.
Paul might meet his grisly fate in the first
movie, but Butters still gets flashback appearances
in Saw IV and V.
But he could have had an entirely different
fate in the "Saw" series.
As he told Vulture,
"Originally, the role I was offered was Jigsaw.
Which, as you know, in the first script, really
did not have a whole lot to do, so I kind
of said no, which was probably a mistake!"
It's intriguing to play "what if" and wonder
what Butters could have done with the part.
Paul Gutrecht gets one of the worst, hardest-to-avoid
deaths in Saw, having to walk on broken glass
holding a candle while smeared in flammable
jelly to figure out how to get an antidote
for poison that's already in his veins.
That's a very rigged game, and it's not surprising
Mark loses.
"Saw" was Gutrecht's final movie appearance
before he went on to pursue another career
as a licensed therapist, but he did have several
guest-starring roles on TV.
In particular, he was a favorite of showrunner
Matt Nix, who used him in Burn Notice, The
Good Guys, and Complications.
Michael Emerson, who plays fake-out villain
and reluctant Jigsaw accomplice Zep Hindle,
wound up having one of the most interesting
post-Saw careers of the whole cast.
While he appeared in a few more movies, Emerson's
strongest work has been on TV, where he's
found several awesome, intriguing roles that
really showcase his talent.
Even before Saw, Emerson had an Emmy Award-winning
guest star run on the legal drama The Practice,
but it was only after Saw that his career
really took off.
He was cast as Ben Linus on Lost, and the
part catapulted him to national recognition.
His work as Ben won him another Emmy, this
time for Outstanding Supporting Actor in a
Drama Series.
Emerson undeniably made the most of his Lost
success, going on to star in the thought-provoking
sci-fi thriller series Person of Interest,
the historical miniseries The Name of the
Rose, and the supernatural horror drama Evil.
Truly a geek icon.
Benito Martinez's Brett has one of the safest
roles in Saw: He plays Lawrence Gordon's lawyer,
and he gets in and out without attracting
any of Jigsaw's ire.
He even gives solid legal advice.
And once Brett escaped, Martinez continued
an impressive career that's made him one of
TV's low-key MVPs.
He was already starring on The Shield, where
he played the calculatingly ambitious David
Aceveda, and he continued in that role until
the show ended in 2008.
Drawing off his great work there, he's become
a kind of sleeper hit on cable shows and some
of the darker network dramas, with prominent
roles on Sons of Anarchy, House of Cards,
American Crime, The Blacklist, How to Get
Away with Murder, and 13 Reasons Why.
He hasn't worked on as many movies, but he's
still been a part of some great projects,
including Queen & Slim, Beyond the Lights,
and Million Dollar Baby.
Shawnee Smith's Amanda is one of the most
memorable characters in Saw, even with very
limited screen time: Her desperation is vivid,
and she's absolutely mesmerizing as someone
who has fallen under Jigsaw's spell.
The series knew that her character had promise
— and that Smith, who had an established
acting career, especially on TV, was a good
bet.
She became a huge part of the franchise, with
major roles in Saw II and III.
"Game over."
"I'll f---ing kill you!"
Her future Saw appearances, especially with
her significantly expanded part, helped make
Smith into a little bit of a horror name:
It led to her hosting the reality show Scream
Queens in 2008, where she took young actresses
through a competition to win a role in Saw
VI.
But unlike a lot of Saw actors, she didn't
completely redirect her career to horror.
With previous work on shows like Becker, she
still had one foot in comedy, and her most
significant post-Saw work has come on the
FX sitcom Anger Management.
As the menaced and terrified daughter in Saw,
Makenzie Vega doesn't necessarily have much
to do... but to be fair, she was around ten
when the movie was filmed.
In the wake of the film, she went on to grow
up and develop as an actor, eventually demonstrating
some pretty strong dramatic chops.
She really made a splash on the hit CBS show
The Good Wife, where she played series regular
Grace, the opinionated and independent daughter
of lead Alicia Florrick.
Monica Potter imbues Alison Gordon with a
sense of steely poise even though she spends
most of the movie fearing for her and her
daughter's lives.
A few years after Saw, she would play another
memorable horror wife and mother, this time
in the 2009 remake of The Last House on the
Left.
Most of Potter's career, however, has been
in television.
"Saw" overlapped with her time as a series
regular on Boston Legal, where she played
lawyer Lori Colson.
After a few years hopping around between intermittent
projects, including a regular role on TNT's
short-lived Trust Me, she found spectacular
success with NBC's Parenthood, which gave
her a chance to really shine.
Her nuanced performance as Kristina Braverman
won her a Critics Choice Award in 2013.
Since the show wrapped, she's continued to
work in TV, including a lead role on Wisdom
of the Crowd.
Poor Jeff Ridenhour narrowly misses one of
the most humiliating deaths in the franchise.
Jigsaw uses him as a test subject for a trap
— it's not even about him! — and the detectives
who discover him decide to hang back and see
what Jigsaw will do with him before they step
in.
Not exactly great police work.
Ned Bellamy, the actor who played him, has
gotten better treatment as he's developed
a career as a character actor.
As a guest star, he feels like a seamless
part of the ensemble on everything from Scrubs
to Justified to Treme, and he's had a pleasantly
varied movie career with roles in Django Unchained
and Twilight.
Alexandra Chun plays Carla, the medical student
Lawrence has an ill-advised affair with.
After Saw, she went on to have a strong career
that's only getting better over time.
Her biggest movie role so far has been as
the lead in 2013's Innocent Blood, a well-regarded
indie thriller.
And she's done a lot of TV guest star work,
appearing on beloved shows like House, The
Event, The Magicians, and Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Recently, she's gotten more substantial recurring
roles on both Twitch's semi-interactive Artificial
and the Netflix ballet drama Tiny Pretty Things.
"I want to play a game."
Even before Saw, Tobin Bell had built an impressive
body of work: He was someone you could spot
in everything from Tootsie to Goodfellas,
in part because he appreciated any chance
to get on set.
As he told Movieline,
"I viewed it as an opportunity to make $150
a day doing something that I cared a great
deal about, where I could learn."
Saw changed all that, splitting his career
into "before" and "after" stages.
Speaking with the Orlando Sentinel, he called
the movie "a great blessing," and he starred
in multiple Saw sequels, appearing in every
installment even after his character's death
in Saw III.
Understandably, he's now best known as a horror
actor, so he's also appeared in other horror
projects like 12 Feet Deep, Belzebuth, and
Shudder's Creepshow.
But he still occasionally gets to stretch
himself, including with voice work on CW's
The Flash.
"You have no idea what's about to begin."
With his role in the franchise wrapping up,
he's eager to see if his increased star power
can translate to different kinds of roles,
ones very far from John Kramer.
We hope he'll never leave horror behind completely,
but after years of masterfully orchestrating
terror for audiences everywhere, he certainly
deserves a change of pace.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.